it's amazing how much a computer
password can unlock it's like the Open
Sesame to your entire life but some
passwords like Open Sesame are a little
too simple
which means thieves can guess them most
of us now know not to use the most
familiar passwords out there and most of
us know you can add symbols or numbers
to make them harder to guess
the trouble is attackers don't just
guess passwords they use computer
programs to guess passwords for them and
they can guess millions of passwords a
second the truth is that as humans were
too predictable even when we're trying
not to be inventing a truly random
password takes a non-human mind so how
do you choose a super random password
without the help of a robot that you'll
actually be able to remember get an
ordinary six-sided die and search for
die swear word list on the web die swear
word list has 7776 words on it throw
your die five times and write down each
number you get side by side so if you
throw a 4 a 3 a 5 a 1 and a 6 you get
the number 4 3 5 1 6 look up the word
next to the number 4 3 5 1 6
nikko and that's the first word in your
new random passwords do this 5 more
times until you have 6 words
that's your password you can stick
spaces between the words or add special
characters if you want but you don't
have to that password should be random
enough to protect most treasures from an
automatic password cracker computer
security experts say that as of now
passwords made from 6 random dice where
words will be extremely hard to guess
except by large organizations with big
budgets like the NSA or other spy
agencies use 7 words and you'll be even
safer remember to keep your strong
passwords secret you can use dice where
passwords to create something strong and
memorable use them to lock your computer
or for your password manager but don't
use the same password everywhere find
out more about managing multiple
passwords in our other animations and at
surveillance self-defense the Electronic
Frontier Foundation and thanks to AG
Reinhold creator of the dice word list